okay we have some news about the YouTube
advertiser boycott which is really no
news the latest earnings are six six
cents the youtube channel off of AD
revenue made six cents on april 9th data
is always delayed about 48 hours so it's
not getting better as a result of the
youtube advertiser boycott the david
pakman show has suffered a forty percent
decrease minimum in our revenue I've
also been contacted by I don't want to
say too much Pat but by a major
newspaper that is investigating what's
going on to our Channel and some others
I will just leave it there if this story
breaks will be tweeting about it will be
posting about it you will be aware of it
but in the short term sadly I have no
good news and as a result we still need
to I hate that we have to do this but we
have to go to the audience in terms of
replacing this lost revenue there are a
few different ways that you can help
replace this lost revenue through
YouTube number one is you can get a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership really easy we have a coupon
code you can get a forty percent
discount off of your membership by using
the code i voted 17 to is you can go to
patreon.com/scishow we've surpassed
twelve hundred individual patrons there
so that is really really great and I
think it's it just shows that people
understand the urgency of what's going
on number two if you ever shop on amazon
by going to david pakman.com slash
amazon you'll be redirected to amazon in
a way that will send us a five to eight
percent kickback for everything you buy
no forms to fill out nothing else to do
you can also if you have YouTube red
which is the ten dollar a month youtube
subscription which lets you watch all
videos ad free if you watch our videos
enter a YouTube red subscriber we will
get a portion of that ten dollars a
month if enough people do it it can add
up and lastly you can get your gear
coffee sweatshirts t-shirts and bumper
stickers at david pakman.com slash gear
this is a cumulative process we've got
to keep it going here's a screenshot
from patreon i believe as of just a few
hours ago this
is just before we crossed the 1200
patron line which we have now crossed we
estimated that the average youtube
viewer if they watched all hundred and
sixty of our monthly videos we're
contributing about thirty to fifty cents
to us through YouTube ad revenue if you
donate one dollar at patreon.com slash
david pakman show you make it up okay
and then as far as membership good news
there people continue to sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership to use
the coupon code you select your
membership level you click the red sign
up button and then on the second page
you will see the coupon code field you
can enter i voted 17 and that will give
you a forty percent discount if you want
it if you don't want or need the
membership by all means pay full price
and we end up getting a little more of
the money i will keep you posted on what
goes on there today's program is made
possible in part by gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30 day free trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the games I think I mentioned
that you can also rent games through the
mobile app get a free 30 day trial for
david pakman show viewers and listeners
and support our show at gamefly
offer.com /td PS